a Democrat just like the mayor of New
York City Eric Adams a Democrat joining
me now is Brandon Judd president of the
national border patrol Council Brandon
great to have you this on the program
this evening Joe Biden Brandon has said
that the real fault in this situation
does not lie with his administration but
actually relies with a man who hasn't
been in office for two and a half years
he still blames it on President Trump
Brandon he blames it on Maga Republicans
what do you say
well let's fact check him in real time
that's absolutely false all we have to
do is look at what what was took place
under the Trump Administration we had
the most orderly immigration system in
the in in my history in 25 years of
doing this job I'd never seen anything
that was more orderly than under
President Trump then you look at the
numbers that we apprehended under
President Trump we dropped to 45-year
lows something that said that this
Administration completely ignores look
at the number of look at the amount of
fentanyl that was on our streets it was
at all time lows under President Trump
because we were able to go after the
criminal cartels in real time that is
fact checking right now when you look at
what's going on under this
Administration we are seeing more
fentanyl on our streets than we've ever
seen before we're seeing more deaths of
United States citizens than we've ever
seen before we're seeing more crime than
we've ever seen before by illegal
immigrants in the United States we're
also seeing more deaths of those people
that are crossing our borders illegally
we're seeing more drownings than ever
before we're seeing more deaths in the
in the deserts than we've ever seen
before everything is at record high
under this Administration and it's all
based upon their policies they changed
policies that were working that
President Trump implemented and because
of those changes we're seeing a complete
chaos on our borders and everything is
allowing our car is allowing the cartels
to generate more profit than in any time
in my 25-year career which again is
killing more United States citizens we
have to care where we hope that this
Administration would care more about the
American citizens than their political
aspirations but unfortunately that's
that's more on those policies their
political aspirations than the American
people more on those policies in just a
moment Brandon take a look at these
numbers you're in the Tucson sector I
believe you can see the numbers what's
happening just in that sector alone 11
000 apprehensions this week as you
mentioned the many other angles of this
entire tragedy you can see the number of
Narcotics events and human smuggling
involved as well but I want to move to a
potential solution Brandon and I think
every American respects and appreciates
the job that border patrol does even
with at times its hands politically tied
but many Americans have asked for more
not necessarily from border patrol but
from any politician they've asked for
State Governors to declare an invasion
giving them powers to invoke their own
National Guard to address the problem
Governor Greg Abbott of Texas today did
so Brandon he put up a declaration he
invoked Article 1 Section 10 Clause 3 of
the United States Constitution which he
says gives him the power to declare an
invasion and do the following things on
your screen which is most importantly
probably that bottom one repel migrants
he said in that declaration by the way
to the border now Brandon that's
normally a job of border patrol but I
think at this point Americans are saying
anyone everyone
stop triage stop the bleeding is this
something you believe will help
it will as long as we remove people
immediately if we end Catch and Release
if we end the reward that releases
people into the United States people
will stop coming that's what's so
amazing about what this is what what
Biden is doing if he would simply enact
policy that would allow us to remove
people immediately from the United
States we would see an immediate
decrease in illegal immigration and when
we see that immediate decrease then
we're able to go after the cartels yes
it will help what what governor Abbott
is going to do let's just hope that he
does it immediately that's right let's
let's watch and make sure it's executed
in Texas Brandon Judd thank you so much
for being with us tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else